c'est la dernière née des salles de
cinéma itinérante toujours en cours
d'installation
ceci n'est mobile mesure près de 14
mètres pour plus de quatre mètres de
haut
capacité d'accueil 100 places ciné
mobile c'est une véritable salle de
cinéma roulante
on a la même qualité de d'assises
on a les mêmes qualités tacite dans une
même qualité de projections voire mieux
parce que vu qu'il ya une seule salle ce
façon on travaille on travaille mieux
l'image en fait on lit plus on est plus
attentif à notre projection
donc on a un très beau piqué d'image et
ça beaucoup de gens nous le disent
pareil la qualité de son nez sur les
mêmes qualités sombre une salle de
cinéma classique
l'hiver on a chaud parce qu'on a des
climatisations réversibles et l'été il
fait frais dans les camions carrossier
constructeur toutankamion est une
entreprise régionale qui a su se
spécialiser sur un marché de niche en
proposant des produits faits sur mesure
ces camions sillonnent la france depuis
35 ans et la société emploie la dont 85
salariés chiffre d'affaires 18 millions
d'euros il est beaucoup plus efficace de
déplacer le moyen vers les populations
que les populations vers le moyen la
culture en est un exemple on amène le
cinéma dans les zones rurales
mais le dépistage médical c'est la même
chose
juste à côté du ciné mobile on a une
unité de formation aux métiers de bouche
on a réalisé des unités de
de formation aux métiers de la
plasturgie on travaille sur des projets
dans d'autres métiers comme la
métallurgie ou on a développé un vrai
tissu de compétences croisées dans ce
domaine là ciné mobile est un concept
unique en france ni en place par la
région centre val de loire pour rendre
la culture accessible au plus grand
nombre
[Musique]